I'm Brian Greene and today I have been
challenged to explain a topic in five
levels of difficulty
we're going to be talking about the
nature of time the most familiar and the
most mysterious quality of the physical
Universe there is nothing that we
experience that does not take place in
some duration of time so if you can
understand time you're on your way to
understanding reality
[Music]
hello hello what's your name Kayla how
old are you Kayla I am nine years old so
if you're nine years old what does that
mean about the Earth how many times has
it gone around the Sun nine times nine
times so there's a relationship between
motion through space the Earth is going
through space
and the passage of time they're kind of
connected in some way but there are
differences right
if I asked you to move through space you
could do it freely right can you get up
and let's see how easy it is to move
through space can you move over to that
location and can you come back
anything getting in your way easy to do
yep if I were to ask you to sit
perfectly still in space can you do that
I mean hold perfectly still
that's good but if I ask you to hold
still in time
to not go to the next second or the next
second
can you do that no so there's definitely
this difference between space and time
some fundamental quality that
distinguishes how freely we can move
through space versus how freely we can
move through time have you heard of
Albert Einstein yes what do you know
about him yes please
here and I think I may be heading in
that direction actually he showed us an
approach to travel to the Future you
want me to tell you how you do it
you build a spaceship you go out into
space really quickly you turn around and
you come back to planet Earth and he
showed us that when you're on that ship
your clock will tick off time more
slowly you will age more slowly so that
Journey may only take you say a year six
months out and six months back but you
know what when you step out of the ship
it'll be a hundred years into the future
or a thousand years a million years into
the future would you do that if you
could I would probably be dead by that
no you'd be alive that's the amazing
thing I'd be to everybody else would be
dead who stayed on Earth but your body
would only age one year and yet it would
be a thousand years into the future the
question though is could you get back
and I don't know the answer to that
nobody does we don't know if you can
travel back but we certainly know that
you can travel forward has anyone ever
tried to go forward and back I don't
think so that same guy with the crazy
hair Albert Einstein showed that there's
actually a limit to how fast things can
go and you know what the limit is the
limit is the speed
light because light travels
671 million miles per hour that is fast
enough to go around the entire Earth
seven times in one second so if we could
build a spaceship that would go as fast
as light we'd be able to do what
Einstein noted there's something else
that's really curious about time things
tend to go in One Direction and we call
it the arrow of time it sort of points
from the past into what we call the
future if you'd ask me why is there an
arrow to time ask me why is there an
error at the time I'm not really sure I
have some ideas but I'd say we've still
not completely nailed it down Kayla what
have you learned about time from talking
about it here that you can't really
travel back through time and can you
travel to the Future in Prince maybe
maybe that's absolutely right I think
it's unlikely we'll learn how to travel
to the past but it's not been ruled out
that's kind of exciting that it's still
at least an open possibility
if I was to ask you what is time
what would you say time is
kind of strange because it's almost a
man-made idea there is the tangible of
you know how the Earth revolves around
the Sun or how we orbit around ourselves
it's almost in a way does it exist if
the way that we measure it is man-made
before there's any life on planet Earth
I think we all agree the universe
existed did things change before there
was life on Earth yes and how would you
talk about that change without invoking
this concept of time it's difficult to
talk about something without adding time
into it even if it is a human-made
concept that the Universe evolved
developed changed Through Time
ultimately giving rise to Galaxy stars
planets and on this particular Planet
life that conception of time gives it
feel that it's like Universal that it's
out there it's the same for everybody
it's independent of our actions or
activities do you know that Albert
Einstein shattered that view of time he
found that if you and I say have
identical wrist watches I'm sitting
still and I'm watching you move I will
find that your clock is taking off time
more slowly than my clock you know it's
really remarkable you can figure out
this quality of time if you know one
fact that the speed of light is constant
have you ever heard that phrase my
freshman year physics class yeah if
you're clever you can use that with high
school algebra maybe even a little high
school trigonometry to make it even
easier to derive that clocks take off
time at different rate do you want me to
show you how that goes yes please
right so to figure out the effect of
motion on time I'm going to use a really
simple clock it's called a light clock
it's two mirrors
that are facing each other and what we
do is we have a little ball of light
called a photon right that goes up hits
the top mirror then comes back down and
hits the bottom mirror and every time it
does that you go Tick Tock that's one
unit of time imagine now we have another
one of these light clocks but I'm going
to have it in motion now what do you
notice
about that path it's much longer it's
much longer right this one's going tick
tock tick this is going to go tick
tick tock in fact we can figure out the
ratio let's consider time on the
stationary clock compared to time on
this moving clock well that ratio is
going to be the ratio of the lengths
then this would be given by D over L
more time on the stationary because it's
longer distance on the moving clock well
this length over here
that's the same as this L over here
right so we want D over L now you may
have recalled that in trigonometry
there's a name for L over d
sine of theta
opposite is l
hypotenuse is d right and so this ratio
is just 1 over
sine of theta so if we can figure out 1
over sine Theta we'll have our beautiful
formula for the ratio of time on the
stationary clock to time on the moving
clock we just need one other fact the
speed of light along this diagonal is
equal to what we call C C equals speed
of light
but in order for this ball of light to
hit that point on the mirror the
component of the speed of light in the
horizontal Direction better be keeping
perfect Pace with the speed of the clock
itself so let's assume that this clock
is moving in this Direction with the
speed equal to V so c times cosine Theta
must be equal to
the speed of the clock in motion and
from this we learn that cosine Theta is
equal to V over C
there's another beautiful identity you
may recall from your study of
trigonometry that sine squared theta
plus cosine squared theta
is equal to one this is really just a
Pythagorean theorem in Disguise and from
that we can now solve for sine squared
theta equals 1 minus V over c squared
and if for sine Theta is the square root
of this and now we're basically done
because
we already had over here that this ratio
is 1 over sine Theta which now is 1 over
square root of 1 minus V over C
squared so you see as V gets very close
to C this gets very close to one one
minus something very close to one is
very close to zero one over something
close to zero is huge which means the
ratio of time on the stationary to time
the moving that can be a huge number as
the speed of the moving clock approaches
the speed of light now I did this for a
light clock but it's true for any clock
and this is what Einstein discovered in
1905 with his special theory of
relativity do you think that in the near
or foreseeable future of humans as we
know ourselves now will there be a time
where we are using these formulas and
these Concepts in our daily lives as
technology progresses the barrier
between the limitations of experience
and the truth of how the world behaves
in extreme environments will be moved in
the very same way that you know we can
toss a pack of gum and we know where to
put our other hand to catch it well we
have that kind of intuition about these
ideas I think it's quite possible
what are you studying right now I'm
doing physics and computer science so
have you spent any time thinking about
this weird quality of the laws of
physics that there's no mathematical
distinction in the laws between forward
and time and backward in time is that
something you're familiar with yeah and
the one thing that really confuses me
there I'm thinking about uh one of the
most basic things we learn I guess from
Interstellar is that the universe is
expanding or space is expanding and so
I'm thinking how does that square with
gravity and electromagnetism which is
like kind of predicated on the density
of charges or masses the fact that space
expands is perfectly compatible with our
understanding of all the forces of
nature because all of them continue to
operate in a somewhat more subtle way
but we have a beautiful
prescription for taking any law that we
understand in the simpler context a flat
space time and juicing it up so that it
works in a curved space-time the more
philosophical question is in any of
those formulations if you replace T by
minus t and you do it properly in the
equations the equations still work but
if past and future are kind of treated
on equal footing in the fundamental
equations why are they so different from
the perspective of experience when
you're talking about the perspective
experience could you is that just human
subjective experience or actual
observation for physics well certainly
it starts with human subjective
experience but then we are able to
elevate it to a more objective
description for instance when we
introduce words like disorder and order
an entropy in the second law of
Thermodynamics and the equation usually
the way we say it is s equals K log W
entropy equals boltzmann constant times
log of a particular quantity which is
ultimately counting the number of
distinct configurations that A system
can be in what boltzmann and others
showed is that entropy
tends to increase toward the future but
the key word there is tends to increase
so this Arrow of time going from the
past to the Future rests on a curious
Foundation it's a statistical Foundation
which says that it's more likely for
eggs to Splatter than unsplatter it's
more likely for glasses to smash than
unsmash but not that it's impossible for
those things to happen
you just have to wait a really long time
for there to be a reasonable chance of
it ever taking place when you said that
um you know it's more likely for an egg
to smash or for glass to smash and
that's probably because there's so many
atoms so much stuff going on yes but I'm
thinking if we zoom in on like a single
thing I guess do we have variations that
are extremely unintuitive because you
know things can happen in a way that
isn't a statistical average if I take a
film of that electron it's a little
fanciful to describe it that language
because you know about quantum mechanics
and so forth but I take a film of a
little particle moving around and I show
you that film you'll be really
hard-pressed to determine whether I've
shown you the film running forward in
time or whether I've shown you the film
going in reverse time if I had two or
three or four or a gazillion particles
into the mix then it will be much easier
for you to determine whether the film is
going forward in time or backward in
time but order and disorder don't have
much meaning if there's only one
particle and that's why the fundamental
laws don't draw a distinction but the
macroscopic experience does but it
raises a key question where'd the order
of the egg come from if everything goes
toward disorder how do I get this
orderly collection of atoms called an
egg well you probably would say from a
chicken but then I say to you where'd
the chicken come from and you say from
an egg but there's actually some real
insight we can draw from this because if
we keep going back with the chicken and
egg story we'll go back through the
evolutionary lineage of Life we'll go
back to early moments of the sun and the
Galaxy and ultimately the universe each
step taking us to greater and greater
order so we believe that the ultimate
source of order is the Big Bang itself
highly ordered beginning called the bank
and we have been living through the
degradation of that order ever since we
still don't really have a solid
explanation for why the Big Bang had to
be or was high highly ordered at the
moment it's really a deep assumption
Einstein we wondered does time change
with speed and that's another change
with that before we didn't think
possible but I guess we found out
eventually some of the fanciful ideas I
guess there's a tiny sliver of Hope yeah
not only did we find that time changes
with speed and special relativity but we
also found that time changes with
gravity Einstein showed that the rate at
which a clock ticks slows down based
upon the stronger gravitational field or
gravitational potential actually that it
is experiencing I think you mentioned
Interstellar before do you remember the
scene in interstellar they're going to a
planet that's near a black hole they go
down to the planet and they spend just a
couple hours there but when they go back
to the ship it's 23 years later on the
ship because time is elapsing slowly
near the strong gravitational field
comparatively quickly far away and
that's not science fiction that's
actually how time behaves I've always
heard people say oh general relativity
you know it might not seem applicable
but you know GPS due to satellites yeah
we could synchronize those Clocks by
accounting for relativity well but
that's even a really really good point
the GPS would become completely
inaccurate in a very short period of
time if the satellites weren't taking
account of or the software wasn't taking
account of the fact that time elapses
differently for the clocks on the
satellite compared to the clocks down
here on Earth so we walk around with
general relativity in our pockets even
though most of us perhaps don't really
know that
have you started any projects yet or
that's I'm just starting one right now
I'm trying to figure out how stars in
the galaxy are moving based on what
they're made of which is interesting
clearly time comes in to what you're
doing to what extent do you have to
Grapple with some of the subtle features
yeah with my research in particular I
really want to know what happened in the
past and what happened in the future but
you only get a single snapshot when you
look up at the night sky right but if
it's officially far back you're right
and so we can learn a lot by looking at
other galaxies and seeing what they were
doing in in their present I suppose yeah
just figuring out what's gonna happen
next is is part of part of the issue
yeah that's looking into the future I
suppose and so have you taken general
relativity are you taking that now or I
took a course on general relativity yeah
but you learned about black holes sure
one of the weird things and wonderful
things about wormholes is that they are
tunnels if you will shortcuts from one
point in space to another point in space
but once you have a shortcut from here
to there the beautiful thing is if you
move the openings
time will elapse differently at the
different openings so there's a
possibility of wormholes as time
machines go One Direction you're going
into the future go the other direction
you'd be going into the past but that of
course raises philosophical and logical
Paradox paradoxism sort so what do you
think what do you I throw it to you yeah
I've heard a few different theories that
people pause it maybe it is Back to the
Future and you really change your own
Universe I've also heard people say that
you could have a multiple universes
Spawn from this event or something yeah
that's that's if you're going to be able
to change the past that's the one that
resonates most with me I think the same
yeah so you go into the past and maybe
you can prevent your parents from
meeting but you're preventing them from
meeting in a parallel reality which
means that you will never be born in
that reality but the origin of your
birth is still completely understood it
was in the universe from which you
originated another one that's more
subtle is the laws of physics May
prevent you from interceding right and
that raises uncomfortable issues for
many people having to do with like free
will I'm immediately uncomfortable yeah
so that one there's actually some people
like Joe
who did some wonderful studies of
billiard ball tables where you imagine a
billiard ball goes into a wormhole comes
out and hits the very ball that was
going into the hole and in that way if
it could knock it of course we seem to
be in some logical Paradox absolutely
but the finding was the ball can come
out and just sort of graze the other one
but it can't affect it enough to prevent
the sequence of events from happening
and the way I like to think about it
frankly is if there's one Universe not
parallel universes like in the other
solution moments in time
just are they don't change the whole
point of time is the variable along
which change can happen so if you have
the atoms of time the individual events
there's no conception of them changing
so whatever collection of influences
were in play that allowed your parents
to meet they will always be in play
because you were always part of that
moment do you think travel back to the
past is impossible because of a deep
physical like mathematical reasoning or
just because of all of these problems
that you've been talking about I suspect
that when we fully understand the
mathematics of the final physical laws
if we ever come upon them I think
there's going to be something built in
okay that prevents this kind of free
travel to the past but sometimes I I
wonder if that's just coming from a more
emotional place where I sort of want the
world to be safe from this kind of
paradoxes so what pretty clear based on
any of the hypothetical proposals for
traveling to the past that have come out
of physics you can't
travel to a moment in the past before
the first time travel machine is built
sure you know the twin paradox yeah sure
where you know you fly off looks like
you're moving fast but to you it looks
like the other guy is moving fast so who
actually ages more who ages less yeah a
resolution I've heard is that because
you have to be going away and then
coming back you had to accelerate at
some point and this breaks the the
ambiguity yeah what if say the universe
isn't flat what if the universe is
curved and you go off in One Direction
and then you come back in the same
direction you pass by the Earth who's
older then yeah do we have an answer
yeah we do have an answer so the
simplest version of that is imagine that
the Universe has a shape of a donut
imagine I'm on the circular part of this
donut Universe all right and imagine I
turn on two laser beams sending a beam
of light going to my right and to my
left and these beams will go around the
entire entirety of space and will both
come back and at some point they will
hit me imagine they hit me at the same
moment from my perspective now imagine
someone's moving relative to my frame of
reference say to my left they do the
same experiment they fire the beam of
light left and right notice that the
beam that they fired to their left will
have to travel farther to reach them
because they're moving away from it
whereas the beam that they fired to
their right will not have to travel as
far because in some sense they're moving
toward it the two beams of light will
not hit that moving Observer at the same
moment to you or to them to them wow
which means that there's a preferred
frame of reference in this universe
everybody is not on equal footing as
they are when we teach to freshmen the
special theory of relativity that's
right exactly no everybody else is
moving relative to me and it's real
emotion so everybody else will be like
the moving twin they will be younger and
I will be older and when you think about
past and future on a cosmological scale
there was a long period when there were
no human beings in the universe the fact
of the matter is there will be these two
long stretches with our presence being
sort of a flicker in between to that
thought inform anything about how you
live in your brief flicker within that
brief flicker I rage against thinking
like that
yeah I think that's the perfect way to
put it yeah because it might be a brief
flicker on a single moat of dust like
floating in a cosmic eternity yeah but
it's everything yeah there's nothing
else that I'll ever experience and so in
a way there's there's nothing else to me
yeah there's an eternity but I'm never
gonna see it I'm never gonna feel it it
can be debilitating to imagine an
eternal future of sort of nothing or
none of what we do sort of persists on
the other hand if you flip your
perspective around and say how
remarkable is it that we have this brief
moment that allows us to think and feel
and love and explore and illuminate wow
how wonderful is that yeah
so often when we try to give the basic
idea of what time is I'm fond of saying
look space is the language that allows
us to say where events take place and
time is the language that allows us to
specify when they take place where would
you jump off from there and trying to
give a deeper understanding of the
basics of time maybe part of the
distinction in between time and space
it's that you have a clear irreversible
Evolution so how to explain what time is
well it's a parameter that is measured
by clocks I mean at the end this is what
we know and allows us to talk about
change and also that we know how to
describe in terms of some set of
equations which gives a clear sense of
causality to note our recent paper where
we were thinking about Einstein's ideas
of special relativity but in a setting
where the global shape of the space-time
if you imagine there might be a curled
up dimension of space a circular
Dimension and thought about how special
relativity Works in that setting we came
to result in this very basic setting you
can send signals into the past not in a
way that will violate causality did that
surprise you that by going from the
usual topology that doesn't have a
closed part of space but making that one
change you could have this radical
impact I found quite surprising that you
could have this exotic behavior of a
signal propagation in a system that was
extremely simple totally classical there
was nothing weird except one dimension
that was compactified was identified on
a circle actually even the standard
vanilla
causal structure of special relativity
may give some very unexpected behaviors
when you combine it with other simple
modifications of just the flat space
time and the beauty of it is it's not
like there is some high-powered
mathematical methodology
straightforward algebra that a high
school kid would know is all that you
need to extract these unusual results
and they were unusual because even if
you do not violate causality we
discovered that a fast moving Observer
that could be us on a rock it could send
signals verifier and then back in a very
small time so the old idea that of
course we always hear about that if we
ever make contact with extraterrestrial
life they're far away we can't really
have a conversation because we'll say
hello and then like 10 000 years or a
hundred thousand years later they'll
answer us because it'll take that long
for the signals but at least in this
setup which we don't know is true of our
universe but if it were then you could
have a real time Conversation Over
arbitrarily large distances yes which is
that was unexpected yeah and so that
shows how even ideas that seem to be
well settled and well understood have
surprises like why didn't Einstein
realize this yes yeah maybe the idea of
living on a Subspace or being confined
in this extra dimension on a Surface may
have been looked exotic but definitely
did not look exotic after the 1990s many
people have begun thinking about the
possibility that space and time may be
so-called emergent quantities that
they're not as fundamental as perhaps
Newton or Einstein would have thought
where do you stand on that idea it seems
not Unthinkable saying that something is
emergent will make full sense only when
we have some concrete model in which
space and time emerging in which we make
sense of this non-space non-time
description of a theory I don't know if
we are still at this stage in which I
would say we begin to understand this
scenario because often I tell my
students the greatest scientific
revolution has been not in the 20th
century it has not been quantum
mechanics nor general relativity no
special relativity it has been the
passage from the qualitative description
of nature to quantitative one when you
pass from asking how to how much right
then you understand something and who do
you credit with as that Newton do you go
a little bit below I would say Galileo
Newton of course the the completion of
this idea is Newton one of the things
that relativity also sheds a light on is
what exists that if someone's moving
relative to me what they consider now
might be in my past what they consider
now might be in my future which would
suggest that all of time exists much
says we're willing to accept that all of
space exists does that hold water
actually it resonates with me for
various reasons one is that
professionally we use space-time
diagrams Penrose diagrams a lot of
diagrams where space and times are just
two axis on a board and when we describe
a particle we have a line that goes up
in time by the way this image also is
the last image improves the last page
there is this beautiful sentence which
is also true saying that if he has the
time he would like to describe people as
being monstrous beings that extend in
time much longer than in space if it's
equal to one that's very true so this
idea that you have a Continuum and the
time should not be made to disappear as
soon as it's gone it's very practical
it's also what is behind the idea of
histories in quantum mechanics when in
the approach of various people including
heart or collaborated a lot with Hawking
there is this idea that what you
describe is a history it's not a
particular moment in time but it's an
evolution this history treats space and
time on a more equal basis but would you
say there's more to it than the
technical more to it than the diagrams
more to it than sort of an
interpretation of the mathematical
equations when you go so far as the text
solace in the fact that that in a sense
that you will always exist because you
will always be at the moments of space
and time that you have occupied
throughout your life well actually
that's probably the only way in which
you can take solace because all the rest
right it's almost children's stories
yeah I mean of course it's something
that you come by yourself you arrive at
this conclusion which is totally not
objective and is part of your personal
history by yourself but it was
interesting to see that for instance
Kurt Vonnegut had exactly the same thing
I said no I mean the only thing that
really makes you not fear what will
happen or your own is that every instant
is eternal instances exactly as each
point in space it's not the space
disappears it will always be there yeah
the idea that something is irretrievable
maybe it's an accident and we go back
again to order the initial conditions in
which we started absolutely
foreign
of time I hope that you have appreciated
the subtlety and the richness of this
quality of the world that we experience
all the time thanks so much for watching
[Music]